let's bring in wyoming republican
congresswoman liz chaney vice chair of
the january 6 committee congresswoman
thanks for being here thank you for
having me brett good to be with you
what
did you make of the vice president and
the president's speeches today in
statuary hall well i i thought that um
there were a number of things that they
said that i agreed with
i think when you when you look at what
happened and at the attack uh that
happened on january 6 i think it's
different
from what happened on 9 11 different
from pearl harbor obviously 3 000
americans died in each of those
events each of those attacks
but but this was a mob that was summoned
by and provoked by the president of the
united states
in an effort to stop the counting of
electoral votes which is a
constitutional
process and so i do think the attacks
are very different i think there is a
grave threat certainly to our system
to our constitutional institutions and i
think we have to set partisanship aside
and party politics aside to get to the
bottom of what happened and make sure
that it doesn't happen again
what do you say to republicans who
listen to that and obviously you address
the 911 comparison the pearl harbor
comparison but they also listen to a
pitch for voting rights bills hr1 and
hr4 are both bills you voted against
yet democrats are using and linking
those to make a sales pitch essentially
for passing those pieces of legislation
based on the work of your committee and
this day
well i i have strong policy uh
disagreements with both hr one and hr
four as you noted i voted against those
i think the committee has important
legislative work to do though we need to
look at things like are there reforms
necessary to the electoral account act
we need to look at things like are there
enhanced penalties that are necessary
for
a president who fails to come to the aid
of congress uh who fails to come to the
aid of any co-equal branch of government
uh we need to look at things like the
dereliction of duty uh when president
trump you know we know he sat in the
dining room next to the oval office
while the attack was underway he could
have at any moment taken a few steps
down the hall to the briefing room gone
on live television and urged his
supporters to stop and go home and he
didn't do that and so there are real
legislative questions the committee
needs to to answer and needs to think
about but that doesn't mean that we're
going to have complete agreement or that
i certainly agree with policy matters
that i have not agreed with in the past
when you hear trump supporters point to
that speech that he made on the mall
saying supporters should peacefully and
patriotically march to the capitol what
what do you say
look i think that you have to look at
the speech you have to look at the
extent to which he was urging people to
fight like hell you have to look at
the extent to which he had been for
months
weeks before that telling people come to
washington it'll be wild i also think
that you have to look at what he has
said since he continues to suggest that
the violence on january 6 was justified
when he says november 3rd was the
insurrection and january 6th was a
protest
what he's doing is continuing to
undermine our electoral process you know
he's gone to war with the rule of law
and i think that's also really important
for people to understand we had over 60
state and federal courts that heard his
claims many of them were trump judges
they heard the evidence in many of those
cases and they rejected them and the
president of the united states
is has got a fundamental constitutional
responsibility to ensure that the laws
are faithfully executed and and that is
what donald trump failed to do
what's the ultimate goal of the january
6th committee
we have several goals one is obviously
the legislative purpose
that i've mentioned the extent to which
there may be legislation
or enhanced penalties for example that
we need to look at to make sure this
never happens again
we also need to ensure the american
people know the truth that the american
people understand
minute by minute you know we we know for
example that president trump attempted
to pressure
the people in his justice department he
said he was going to name jeffrey clark
to be attorney general uh that he
intended to do that jeffrey clark has
now told the committee he wants to take
the fifth
and the entire leadership of his justice
department threatened to resign we know
his white house counsel also threatened
to resign we know president trump
pressured local government officials to
try to overturn the election all of
those things are a fundamental threat to
our democracy and things that have got
to be investigated the american people
need to have the truth about what
happened
but it sounds like congresswoman that
the goal of the committee perhaps is to
go after trump's inner circle and
prevent the former president from
running for president again
is that a fair assessment of the goal no
the goal of the committee is what i said
you know we are a committee of congress
our responsibility is a legislative
purpose to determine what laws we have
in place what additional laws we might
need to prevent
an attack like that from ever happening
again
and we need to understand what happened
we need to know
what members of this body
were doing what they were engaged in one
of my colleagues scott perry for example
was very active and attempting to have
jeffrey clark appointed as attorney
general we need to understand what
happened you know the peaceful transfer
of power is fundamental to the survival
of our republic and we all have a duty
to ensure that peaceful transfer power
every four years
what about the security failure here the
capitol police the architect of the
capital the senate sergeant of arms have
all turned over requested documents
to the house administration's committee
overlooking the security aspect the
house sergeant-arms has not
speaker pelosi has said that
that the house sergeant of arms
requested the national guard passed a
note there are open questions about the
speaker's
involvement and interactions with the
sergeant of arms during that time and
yet chairman thompson has announced on
your committee that the speaker's office
is off limits and that there's no call
for those documents for the house
sergeant of arms
why why is that if if it's designed to
prevent something like that like this
from not happening again well uh look
the the committee itself is very focused
on on that issue you know we have an
entire leg entire investigative team
focused on the security failures that
day focused on the response of that day
um we've got investigators who are
looking at exactly the kinds of things
that you've mentioned so so that that is
a really important set of issues no
office is off limits no issue is off
limits we certainly need to get to the
bottom of that but it's important brett
to remember that if you say that the
security lapses at the capitol are to
blame for the assault on the capital by
a mob provoked by president trump that's
the same thing as saying that the small
business owners whose businesses were
burned to the ground last summer by
antifa and blm rioters that the small
business owners are responsible for that
and that's wrong so so security lapses
are absolutely something that this
committee is looking at and focused on
and it's one piece of a much larger
issue that includes the former
president's uh efforts to overturn the
results of the election
so you would you would push for the
house sergeant of arms to cooperate and
hand over documents and the speaker's
office to cooperate as well despite
chairman thompson's comments well they
and they certainly are uh and i
i think that you know what you're
describing as chairman thompson's
comments uh are not accurate uh it's not
an accurate description of what the
chairman has said uh and and you know he
leads the committee and as i said you
know we've got five investigative teams
on the committee and one of those five
teams is focused precisely on this all
of our teams are staffed with
non-political professional prosecutors
and investigators and those security
issues are going to be a focus of one
part of this investigation
what do you say to somebody sitting at
home who may say listen i think that day
was horrible what happened that day was
horrible but i'm worried about getting
my kids to school i'm worried about
what's happening with covid i'm worried
about the next economic blip that i may
face and they look at the focus on 1-6
and say
why is this so important that i have to
that everything else gets pushed off to
the side what do you say to them
that i absolutely share those concerns
you know i i voted with president trump
93 percent of the time more than most
republican members of the of the house
of representatives i'm a conservative
republican i believe that the policies
the biden administration are bad for
this country but i also know that this
country must go forward on a basis of
truth we've got to be faithful to the
constitution and the rule of law and
that if we aren't faithful to those
things and if we don't tell the truth
about history then the institutions
themselves begin to unravel so if we
want to be in a position where we can
advocate conservative policies again
we've got to tell the truth about
january 6th and we have to make sure
that it never happens again
so why did the wyoming republican party
pass this resolution to no longer
recognize you as a republican and put
out this long lengthy statement about
how you're closer to nancy pelosi and
they have a problem with that why well i
would note the vote was 31-29 so it was
a it was a close run thing
and and certainly there are people in
the state party apparatus of my home
state who um are quite radical and
some of those same people
include people who were here on january
include a party chair who has toyed with
the idea of secession
so there is there is a very radical
element of the republican party in the
same way that there's a radical element
of the democratic party but but we have
to be in a position where we are able to
come together where we're able to focus
on substance on policy and i look
forward very much to putting my record
of delivering for the people of wyoming
and fidelity to the constitution
up for the people of wyoming to make a
decision about
this this election cycle
last thing quickly and this is kind of
process but
you're the co-chair of the january 6
committee
speaker pelosi put you in that position
who's the ranking member of the
committee well i'm not the co-chair
chairman thompson is the chairman vice
chair yes i'm the vice chair
and i am the ranking republican
by nature of when i was appointed
the committee i know that that some on
the republican side who are attempting
to obstruct the work of the committee
include my colleague jim banks for
example who's been sending letters to
federal agencies claiming that he is the
ranking member of the committee which
he's not
this committee is a bipartisan committee
it was constituted completely in
accordance with the rules of the house
and with the rules the resolution uh
that created it and and minority leader
mccarthy refused to name people he
pulled back all of the people that he'd
appointed to the committee we're working
in a nonpartisan fashion and we're going
to get our work done
despite attempts to try to block and
obstruct
and will you push for the release of the
hundreds or thousands of hours of
videotape that has not come out
yes i think it's really important for
the american people to have a full
picture there are a lot of conspiracy
theories that people are pushing uh that
are dangerous and that are wrong and i
think people need to have a full picture
of what happened
on january 6 here at the capitol at the
white house and also in the weeks
leading up to it
congresswoman cheney we appreciate you
coming on we want to hear from all sides
thanks i appreciate it thank you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else